i saw the movie i watched half of the
movie like this
because i was so scared no need to be
sorry
does it mean i've done my job you did
your job and then some
her job was to star as the daring and
defiant heroine
of the stomach twisting sequel in this
movie
millie's character reagan has a way to
use her deafness as a defense
when her family is forced to venture
outside the confines of their farm
what i love about your character is
you're not playing
a character who's deaf and that is their
defining characteristic
you're playing a character who happens
to be deaf but who is a warrior who's
brave who's a little bit rebellious
what does that mean to you she's the
heroine she's saving
the world and it's really inspiring it's
helped me
reframe how i can take advantage of all
of these quote disadvantages
and turn it around and make something
more positive like her character
millie is the only person who's deaf in
her family and on set
she helped teach her movie family how to
sign
does john have a different style of
signing than emily or then your brother
in the film noah
yes everybody has a different style of
signing john is
a big signer he uses his science base
quite well
emily on the other hand is more fluid
and artistic she's almost model-like and
noah is just so cute
we're a little bit faster it's so great
to see how open
and excited everybody was to learn her
life experience
also shaped the film in another way as
writer and director john krasinski
recently told
our gail king i thought the beauty too
it would just all the sudden go
quiet yeah yes so we could see it from
reagan's point of view that's it well
that was my favorite thing
i had asked millie's mom if millie could
hear anything or was she completely deaf
and she said she actually can hear
something it's almost like she has an
envelope
that she can hear a low rumble and i
brought that to the sound guys and i
said we have to try to achieve that
what does that mean to you to be able to
have audiences and
probably millions of people be able to
experience
the world through your eyes it's so nice
to be able to see
somebody else watch this film and
understand what the perspective is like
millie got her break when she was 14
years old in the 2017 movie
wonderstruck starring alongside julianne
moore
and michelle williams she auditioned as
a favor to her drama club teacher
never did i think i would become a
professional actor
we don't see that you don't really see
people like me on
the screens that role launched her from
a quiet upbringing with her family in
utah
to hollywood sets and premieres giving
her a platform to
educate the world about deafness and
inspire
others i want kids out there to see
themselves represented
on screen they can be the ones to save
people they don't have to be saved
have you faced those challenges people
feeling like you need to be saved or
people doubting your ability
yeah i would say growing up i
experienced those
types of things all the time people
would maybe feel sorry for me or pity me
and then it made me start to question
myself am i not normal and it was hard
to discover my identity
but um after filming and you know just
kind of growing up a little bit more
i'm finding who i am i can tell people
i'm proud to be deaf
so what's next for you millie well i
just graduated a couple weeks ago from
high school so
that's very exciting i'm thinking maybe
in the future
potentially applying to film school
i'm very interested in writing perhaps
directing
maybe even producing i just want to
remind myself that i shouldn't limit
myself
with her limitless potential she's the
role model
she never had adriana diaz cbs news
pittsburgh